[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
رياض نبداها كالمعتاد
امريكا تتراقب ترامب على حبل المحاكمه
ورئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يرفض التعليق
خطاب تاريخي للبطاله في السعوديه مستهدفات
والرؤيه تقترب والمرحله القادمه لتحسين
الوظائف
اول تسعه ايام من شهر رمضان تسعه ملايين
راكب عبر شبكه الحافلات من والى المسجد
الحرام
في الرابعه ايضا
فيروس ماربورج يقلق افريقيا والسعوديه
تدعو لتجنب السفر الى غينيا الاستوائيه
وتنزل
[تصفيق]
لعبه البادل تدخل سباق الاهتمامات مع
الكره الطائره رياضه رمضانيه حديثه في
السعوديه
حاله من الترقب والجدل السياسي تعيشها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد اصدار
هيئه المحلفين الكبرى في نيويورك تهمن
جنائيه بحق الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وهي سابقه تاريخيه لرئيس مر على كرسي
البيت الابيض وفي احدث ردود الفعل رفض
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن التعليق على
اتهام ترامب من جهه انتقد مايك بين سنايبر
رئيس الامريكي السابق قرار هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى بتوجيه اتهامات للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب واوضح بنس في مقابله مع سي
ان ان توجيه اتهامات رسميه الى الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب سيصبح بالنسبه للشعب
الامريكي مثالا اخر على تجريم السياسه في
البلاد كما عبر برنس عن اعتقاده بان
التوجيه الاتهامات الى ترامب يحمل طابعا
اللا سابق له ويعد امرا شائلا وقد جاب بنس
بلال عند سؤاله عما اذا كانت لائحه
الاتهام ستؤثر على قراره مشان الترشحي في
انتخابات عام 2024 ضد
[تصفيق]
مصدر المتحدث باسم المدعي العام في منهات
سنه
قال فيه ان المكتبه اتصل بمحامي ترامب
لتنسيق تسليم نفسه تحسبا لمحاكمته بشان
لائحه الاتهام الموجهه ضده والتي لا تزال
مخفيه ومن المتوقعه ان يمثل ترامب امام
المحكمه يوم الثلاثاء لتوجيه الاتهام اليه
بحسب مصادر شبكه سي ان فان من المتوقع ان
يتراس القاضي خوان ميرشن جلسه المحاكمه
من واشنطن ينضم الينا الباحث في شون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
سيد ايهاب مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
يبدا معك بموقف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
عندما رفض التعليق على هذه القضيه او على
محاكمه
لماذا برايك يرفض رئيس امريكي التعليق على
قضيه
مهمه وخطيره ايضا وفي توقيت بالغ الحساسيه
اليوم في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اهلا بحضرتك شكرا على الاستضافه واهلا بكل
المشاهدين اعتقد هذا هو الموقف الامثل
للرئيس الامريكي سواء كان جمهوريا او
ديموقراطيا الا يعلق في هذا التوقيت على
مثل هذا الموقف القضائي لانه سيحسب عليه
كل كلمه وكل حرف سننطق به سيحسب عليه على
اي جانب من الجوانب سواء كان جمهوريا او
ديمقراطيا سواء كان معهد او ضد دونالد
ترامب فهذه الخطوه في التوقيت الحالي
اعتقد انها خطوه مماثله وبكل تاكيد نصح
بها من قبل المستشاري القاريين لكن هل هذا
يعني انه لن يكون في دائره الاتهام بانه
احد الممولين سياسيا
لمساله محاكمه دونالد ترامب بكل تاكيد له
وهذا ما تعوز به وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
المحليه هنا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من ان الرئيس جو بايدن وعدد من
قيادات الحزب الديمقراطي من بينهم طبعا
المجلس النواب السابقه واخرون انهم هم
السبب وراء محاوله ما يسمى او النيل
السياسي من الرئيس دونالد ترامب بتحريك او
بالمساهمه في اذكاء نيران هذه القضيه التي
هي اصلا موجوده امام القضاء والتحقيقات
منذ عام 2016
ابانا طبعا الانتخابات الرئاسيه ما قبل
الماضيه
كاننا امام اختبار جديد الان في الولايات
المتحده
للديمقراطيه رئيس امريكي لاول مره في
التاريخ يحاسب
بالتالي سيدي ايهاب الان كيف ينظر داخليا
في امريكا الى هذه القضيه هل هي
بالنسبه لهم بمثابه عداله المنتصر كما يرى
البعض اشبه بما يحصل في بعض دول من محاسبه
رؤساء سابقين
لمن خلفهم يعني ام ان الامر يتعلق بلحظه
حساب عداله تكريس وتقويه للديمقراطيه
الامريكيه بانه حتى اقوى من كان في يوم من
الايام اقوى شخص على كوكب الارض هو الان
امام المحاكمه
طبعا هي من هذا على ذلك بمعنى ان هناك من
يرون فيما يحدث اليوم مع رئيس سابق دونالد
ترامب انه محاوله لاسقاطه سياسيا ومنعه من
الترشح لخوض الانتخابات
وربما الفوز بها بعد ذلك وهناك من يرى من
ان هذا هو العدل وهذا هو القانون الذي لا
يوجد اي شخص فوقه بل الجميع تحته وهذه
التصريحات صدرت طبعا من قيادات الحزب
الديمقراطي بانهم سعداء يرون القانون يطبق
ولا احد يعرف فوق القانون في المقابل طبعا
الجمهوريون وطبعا من خلفهم القاعده
الجماهيريه العريضه والشعبيه الكبيره جدا
للرئيس دونالد ترامب طبعا يرون في هذا
الامر خطوره على الممارسات السياسيه في
البلاد وان هناك قله تتحكم في محاوله منع
ساسه معينين باسمائهم وبشخصيتهم من الوصول
الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه وطبعا يقصدنا
بذلك طبعا الرئيس دونالد ترامب ولكن الح
موجوده اليوم في الحزبه الجمهور الجمهوري
فيما تبدو من التصريحات التي صدرت حتى
اليوم من القياده داخل الحزب حتى من
منافسي دونالد ترامب المقترحين في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه مثل حاكم
فلوريدا تسير في اتجاه ان ما يحدث هو خطا
كبير بحق ساقف
ونعود والبحث فيها السيد ايهاب يعني قبل
ذلك كان ايضا رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
الجمهوري كابل مكارثي اعتبر بان قرار
توجيه الاتهام الى دونالد ترامب الحق
بالولايات المتحده اضرارا كبيرا في كبيره
في وقت يشن ايضا في حلفاء الرئيس السابق
هجوم العنيفا على الديمقراطيين والمسؤولين
القضائيين قال مكارتي ان المدعي العام في
منهاتنا الديمقراطي الفن براج ادار
ببلادنا بشكل لا يمكن اصلاحه في محاوله
للتدخل في انتخاباتنا الرئاسيه اضاف بان
الشعب الامريكي لن يتسامح مع هذا الظلم
ومج لس النواب سيحاسب على استغلاله غير
المسبوق للسلطه اما حاكم فلوريدا روندي
سانتس المرشح الجمهوري المحتمل الانتخابات
2024 فاكد ان اتهامه ترامب مناف للقيام
الامريكيه وقال انه لن يساعد في اي طلب
لتسليم ترامب بعد توجيه اتهام له
ايضا في هذا السياق تجمع انصار ترامب
اماما منزله في بالم بيتش في ولايه
فلاريدا للاحتجاج على لائحه الاتهام
الموجهه ضده من قبل هيئه المحلفين الكبرى
في منهاتهم
[موسيقى]
عود الى ضيفي من واشنطن الباحث في شون
الامريكيه والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
مثل هذه القضيه القضيه
الان تحديدا
وما يمكن يعني ان تذهب اليه ايضا من سيناء
البعض يتحدث عن ان ذلك قد يمهد الباب لفتح
لائحه باتهام قضايا جديده وغيرها من
الامور خلال القادم من الايام لكن سؤال
حول
الحزب الجمهوري اليوم يعني الى اي مدى هذه
القضيه يمكن ان ترسق حاله الانقسام والشرق
العميق داخل داخله ام يمكن ان يحدث اثرا
عكسيا لعاده الوحده الى صفوفه مره اخرى
كيف ينظر الى هذا الامر
اتفق مع حضرتك في الجزء الثاني مع من سؤال
حضرتك فيما يتعلق
بوضع الحزب الجمهوري بعد هذه القضيه اليوم
هناك تكاتف كبير
لقيادات الحزب الجمهوري لانهم يستشعرون
الخطر المحدق بالعمل السياسي داخل الحزب
من قبل الديمقراطيين وان الانقسام الذي
كان موجودا خلال الفتره الماضيه بشكل او
باخر اليوم يجب التغلب عليه لان الجميع في
بوتقه واحده
واحد ابرز قيادات الحزب والرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه يتعرض لمحاوله
اسقاط سياسي بشكل يعتقدون انه مهين ومخالف
للدستور والقانون الامريكي لذلك تاتي كل
التصريحات يعني كما حضرتك ذكرته كما انا
قلت لحضرتك ايضا تصريحات راندي سانتس
وكارتي كما حضرتك ذكرت وقيادات اخرين كثر
داخل الحزب الجمهوري حتى من هم كانوا
مختلفين مع الرئيس دونالد ترامب او ليسوا
مع امكانيه ترشحه لفتره رئ اسه قادمه
الجميع اليوم يتوحد باي معنى هل يمكن ان
يصطف كل هؤلاء خلف دونالد ترامب كمرشح
وحيد للحزب الجمهوري سيد ايهاب ديسانتوس
مايك بنز قال لا في هذا الامر وغيرهم من
الجمهوري
صحيح طبعا ونذكر بان هناك نكهه لمندوبه
الولايات المتحده السابقه في الامم
المتحده اليوم الاسماء الاكثر حظا اذا
يعني نتحدث بمنتهى الشفافيه هو الرئيس
سابق دونالد ترامب ومن خلفه ياتي رونبيسان
بعيدا نوعا ما نذكر ان انتخابات مجلس
المحافظين في حزب الجمهوري خلال الشهر
الماضي تقريبا كانت تشير الى تقدم الرئيس
السابق دور ترامب بما يخرج من 64% من
اصوات الجمهوريين داخل الحزب بالاضافه الى
ان المؤتمرات الانتخابيه التي بداها
الرئيس دونالد ترامب مبكرا تحظى بحضور
جماهير غفير جدا اخرها الذي تم في تكساس
وحضروا اكثر من 17 الف من انصار الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب بالاضافه الى خطابه
الشعبوي وقربه من المواطنين الامريكيين
البسطاء وقدرته على احياء واذكاء الاقتصاد
الامريكي خلال العام
2016 وحتى نهايه فتره رئاسته
واعطاء دفعه قويه لسوق الاسهم الامريكيه
بما رفعها بمقدار 23 الف نقطه القضاء على
البطاله بشكل كبير جدا بين فئات
الامريكيين من اصول افريقيا لم يحققها اي
رئيس قبله على مدار تاريخ الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وايضا قد يكون لذلك
الامر للاسف لم تاخذ مسارها كل هذه الامور
تضعها نتائج انعكاسات سلبيه على دونالد
ترامب يعني الخطر الاكبر ربما من
المستقلين من الجمهوريين الذين لا يرون او
قد يذهبون بعيدا عن دونالد ترامب خاصه بعد
دخوله في جريمه يعني او محاكمته كمجرم هذا
الامر قد يعني يفقده من من الاصوات ومن
شعبيته شيء الكثير حتى عندما ايضا يترشح
ديسانس قد تستغل مثل هذه القضيه في السباق
الانتخابي بينها وبين ترامب كذلك
صحيح طبعا هناك فرص لكل من يترشح في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه خاصه الحزب
الجمهوري هناك ما زال عدم استقرار على
مرشح واحد لكن الامور تسير في اتجاه ترامب
وفكره ادانته ومحاكمته لن تمنعه كما تعلم
استاذ خالد من ان يكون مرشحا بل وربما
يفوز بالانتخابات بل حتى طبقا للقانون
الدستور الامريكي لا يوجد ما يمنعه من
ممارسه مهام منصبه كرئيس للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حتى لو كان داخل السجن الشيء
الوحيد الذي يمنعه من الوصول لهذه المرحله
هو التعديل الرابع عشر في الدستور
الامريكي والذي ينص على انه اذا ما ارتكب
جرما وتمت ادانته به وهو متعلق بالعصيان
المدني او التمرد عندها فقط يتم منعه من
الدخول في السباق الانتخابي لكن حتى
اللحظه لا توجد اي فرص للوصول بهذا
الاتهام الى ادانه للرئيس دونالد ترامب هو
ما يحاسب عليه اليوم او ما يحضر بسببه
امام المحكمه هي قضيه استغلال اموال
الانتخابات اذا ما ثبتت لانه من الممكن ان
تكون هذه الاموال من جيبه الخاص ويستطيع
محاماه ان يثبته انها كانت من جيبي الخاص
ولم تكن مخصصه في حملته الانتخابيه فمن
الممكن ان ياخذ براءه في نهايه المطاف او
حتى تمت ادانته لن تمنعه من خوف شكرا
جزيلا لك الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
حافظوا صندوق الاستثمارات العامه يكشف عن
نصف مليون وظيفه خلفها الصندوق عبر
مشاريعه المتنوع
لليوم الثاني تستمر اعمال قمه الاولويه
العاليه التي تنظمها مؤسسه مبادره مستقبل
الاستثمار في مدينه ميامي الامريكيه
بمشاركه نحو 80 شخصيه قياديه على مستوى
العالم محافظ صندوق الاستثمارات السعودي
ياسر اكد خلال الجلسه ان الاقتصاد
السعوديه خالف التوقعات بخفض البطاله الى
مستويات غير مسبوقه مشيرا لان الصندوق خلق
نصف مليون وظيفه مباشره وغير مباشره
ويستهدف مضاعفتها لتصبح مليون ونصف وظيفه
مباشره وغير مباشره اضافيه بنهايه 2025 من
جهتها بينت سفيره السعوديه لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الاميره ريما بنت بندر
بن سلطان ان رؤيه 2030 خلقت حاله من
الالهام لدى الشباب الذين اتجهوا لرياده
الاعمال بما يشكل 58% بعيدا عن الوظائف
الروتينيه وخلال القمه اكد عمده ميامي
فرانسيز سواريز ان السعوديه باتت تتمتع
بسرعه
وديناميكيه مدهشه في اتخاذ القرارات
رقم تاريخي وغير مسبوق لانخفاض البطاله
بين السعوديين وصل الى 8% وفقا لهيئه
الاحصاء السعوديه الزميل احمد الهادي
يعرفنا على التفاصيل هذا الانخفاض وعلى
ارقام اخرى حول سوق العمل في السعوديه
السعوديه عنوان عريض يحمل خلفه الكثير من
التساؤلات ومن العمل على تخفيفها وهذا ما
تحقق جزئيا بنهايه العام الماضي 2022 ففي
اخر ثلاثه اشهر او ما توصف اقتصاديا
بالربع الرابع من العام الماضي سجلت واحده
من ادنى معدلات البطاله حيث انخفضت الى 8%
فقط هذا الرقم يعني اننا اقتربنا كثيرا من
الوصول الى مستهدف رؤيه السعوديه 2030
لخفض البطاله بين السعوديين الى سبعه في
المئه مع تبقي ست سنوات وتسعه اشهر مده
طويله تبشر بتحقيق ارقام اعلى من
المستهدفات وحول معدل البطاله الاجمالي
الذي يشمل السعوديين وغير السعوديين فقد
انخفضت الى اربعه فاصله ثمانيه في المئه
ويشمل معدل البطاله الاجمالي المقيمين
الاجانب في المملكه الذين شكلوا ما يزيد
قليلا عن ثلث اجمالي السكان في عام 2021
ويحتاج معظمهم الى عقد عمل للعيش في
السعوديه
كيف يبحث العاطل عن عمل في السعوديه سؤال
الاقارب والاصدقاء اكثر اساليب البحث عن
عمل يليه التقدم المباشر لاصحاب العمل ثم
استخدام المنصات الوطنيه مثل جدارات التي
تشمل منصات اخرى مثل منصتي طاقات وساعد
هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه كشفت ايضا عن
استعداد اربعه وتسعين في المئه من
العاطلين للعمل في القطاع الخاص وان
غالبيه الباحثين عن عمل سيقبلون بالعمل
لاكثر من ثماني ساعات في اليوم هذه
الارقام مشاهدينا وغيرها تؤكد التوجه
العام بين اوصاد السعوديين للعمل في كل
القطاعات وان تفضيل العمل في القطاع
الحكومي اصبح شيئا من الماضي
وحول الخطوه التي تلي تحقيق مستدفات رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 في خفض البطاله كدوالي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان في
لقائه الشهير في ابريل عام 2021 اكد
الانتقال الى مرحله تحسين الوظائف لاقل
دخلا
بالرغم هو مهم هل البطاره تزداد وتنخفض
لدينا البطانه انخفضت اذا قدرنا في نهايه
السنه هذه البطاله في خلال خمس سنوات من
رؤيه باربعه في المئه من 14% الى 10% 4%
في اربع سنوات معناته 3%
سوف تكون قبل كثير من عشر
سنوات لكن ما ابغى اعطيه رقم معين ومتى ما
وصلنا لسبعه في المئه سوف نبدا نعمل على
تحسين ثانيه اللي هو تحسين وظائف ورفع دخل
الخمسين في المئه الوظائفهم سيئه
من الرياض ينضم الينا وكيل وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه البشريه للتوطين المهندس
ماجد الضحاوي سيد ماجد حياك الله معي في
نشره الرابعه رقم تاريخي رقم غير مسبوق
وتحقق بشكل سريع اقتربنا من تحقيق
المستهدف قبل تقريبا ست سنوات
نتحدث عن 7% معدل البطاله اريد ان اسال عن
الاسباب التي اوصلتنا الى هذا الرقم في
هذا الوقت من خلال وجهه نظر الوزاره وهي
احدى الجهات الفاعله في هذا الجهه حياك
الله اخي خالد امسي عليك وعلى الساده
المشاهدين ومبروك الشهر عليكم جميعا اولا
بارك للجميع اصول هذا الرقم التاريخي
والغير مسبوق كما ذكرتم الى معدل البطاله
وصوله الى ثمانيه بالمئه وهذا طبعا ما تم
الا بدعم كبير وتمكين عالي من القياده
الرشيده ابرز ما المسببات لهذا النزول
اخوي خالد علي اذكر بعض منها
هو متانه الاقتصاد السعودي ونمو الحاصل في
الاقتصاد السعودي في عام 2022 حيث
الناتج المحلي في الاقتصاد السعودي
بنسبه 8.7
وهذه النسبه يعني اجتاز فيها دول العشرين
بشكل بشكل كبير كان الاكثر نموا بالنسبه
لدول العشرين هذه النسبه كانت كل التوقعات
منظمات الدوليه ترى انها اقصى نسبه ممكن
ان تكون ثمانيه فاصله ثلاثه من عشره ولذلك
لدينا اقتصاد ينمو بشكل بشكل فاعل دخول
السعوديين والسعوديات بشكل كبير الى سوق
العمل وتسجيل اكثر من اثنين مليون و200
الف سعودي سعوديه ضمن التامينات
الاجتماعيه انعكس على هذا على سياسات
وزاره مواد البشريه وبرامج التوطين والدعم
والحقيقه مشاركه الجهات الحكوميه في تطوير
منظومه سوق العمل للدخول هذا العدد من
السعوديه للسعوديات السوق يعني الامر
يقتصر فقط على التوطين ولا هناك العديد من
الحزم من البرامج ومن القرارات من المش
دور كبير في الوصول الى هذا الرقم الحقيقه
يعني
الانشطه والمهن النوعيه والمناطق واطلقت
ايضا برنامج نطاقات المطور ليحقق
مستهدفاته او تقريبا اوصل 92% من مستدعات
الثلاثه سنوات ولكن دعم القطاع الخاص
وتظافر الجهات الحكوميه جميعا في هذه في
هذا القرارات دعم صندوق الموارد البشريه
هدف حيث دعم اكثر من 400 الف
باحث وباحثه في لدخول سوق العمل بميزانيه
تجاوزت الخمسه مليار كل هذه
الممكنات ساعدت على دخول السعوديين الى
سوق العمل
فيما يتعلق بالنساء او السعوديات
الرقم المسجل اليوم ايضا هو رقم مهم
فبالتالي ما هي اهم ايضا القرارات
والمبادرات والبرامج اللي ساهمت في وصولها
الى هذا الرقم وتمكين المراه لهم في سوق
العمل بهذا الشكل
نعم الحقيقه نشهد مثل ما ذكرته يعني ارقام
قياسيه على
نسبه مشاركه المراه كما تعلم زادت من 17
في 2015 2016 الى
تجاوزت مستهدف الرؤيه في عام 30 اللي هو
ثلاثين بالمئه وصلت اليوم الى قرابه 37
بالمئه ايضا انخفاض نسبه البطاله الى 15%
لدى النساء دليل على نجاح هذه السياسات من
ابرز الممكنات طبعا كل القرارات التوطين
اللي ذكرناها سابقا تشمل سواء السعوديات
والسعوديه لدخول سوق العمل وهي ممكن يحافز
كبير عملنا على عدد من البرامج التدريبيه
مثل برنامج تدريب القيادي للقياديات
برنامج التدريب على راس العمل برامج قره
ووصول وهي برامج معنيه بالرعايه للاطفال
وضمان وصول السعوديات الى اعمالهم
بيسر وسهوله عبر يعني عدد من
الحوافز اللي تمكنهم من من الوصول الى
اعمالهم او
من الحضانه للاطفال
هل انخفاض نسبه البطاله عند النساء يعني
ورفع نسبه العمل بالنسبه لهم خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه من 17% للرقم الذي تحقق
اليوم هو سبب الرئيسي اليوم في الوصول الى
8% الوصول الى هذا الرقم التاريخي وغير
المسبوق مهندس ماجد الحقيقه نسبه يعني في
كل الارقام هي هي يعني تشهد ارقام قياسيه
اجمالي نسبه البطاله لدى السكان وصل الى
4.8 اجباري نسبه البطاله لدى السعوديين
وصل الى 4.2 وايضا نسبه مشاركه القوى
العامله لدى السعوديين وصل الى سته ثمانيه
وستين بالمئه وهو ايضا رقم قياسي فنشهد
ارقام قياسيه على كافه الاصعده ولا كافه
المحاور للسعوديين وللسعوديات زياده هذه
المعدلات الخفض ايضا الارقام هذا يتطلب
بالتاكيد جهود كبيره ومتكامله وموحده من
كثير من الجهات الحكوميه والقطاع الخاص
دكتور هذا الى اي مدى كان له دور في
الوصول الى هذا الرقم مقارنه بسنوات ماضيه
ربما
تحقيق هذا المستهدف
اقتصاد ممكن وقطاع خاص ممكن وايضا لا ننسى
قدره وابناء وبنات الوطن الذي اثبتوا
الحقيقه في السنوات الماضيه قدرتهم على
الانخراط في سوق العمل
والعمل بكفاءه عاليه جدا يعطيكم العافيه
وشكرا جزيلا لك مره اخرى من الرياض وكيل
وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه للتوطين
المهندس ماجد شكرا لكم مهندس
اشهد انقطاع استخدام العماله في السعوديه
نقلت النوعيه بعد استحداث منصه مسانده
التي تعمل على توحيد وتسهيل الاجراءات
وحفظ حقوق جميع الاطراف من افراد وعماله
ومكاتب استخدام وفق اسعار مدروسه وتنافسيه
لخدمتي الاستقدام الفوري او الايجار نتابع
عمليه
مساند منصه تستقبل وترد على طلب العميل
خلال 90 دقيقه ليتمكن العميل بعدها من
اصدار تاشيره خلال ثمان دقائق مميزات
متنوعه يقدمها تطبيق مساند حيث يتمكن
العميل من معرفه اسعار الاستقدام والمطبقه
حسب القرار الوزاري اضافه الى اتاحه خدمه
التامين الاختياري على عقود العماله
المنزليه كما يمكن العميل من تقييم اداء
المكاتب بهدف رفع مستوى الجوده
المنصه تتيح كذلك خيارات استخدام 21 مهنه
من 18 دوله من ضمنها تايلند وبيروندي وحسب
احصاءات مساند فان بنغلاديش تاتي اولا في
طلبات الاستقدام ثم الفلبين وباكستان
ثالثا
باقات موسميه محدده الاسعار يوفرها
التطبيق بعد مراجعتها لايجار خدمات
العماله كما يمكن العميل من نقل الخدمات
من منشاه الى فرد في اطار نظام حمايه اجور
العماله المنزليه شاهد المتروك العربيه
[موسيقى]
رابعه مستمره ايضا فيها بعد قليل لعبه
البادل تدخل سباق الاهتمامات مع الكره
الطائره رياضه رمضانيه حديثه في السعوديه
[تصفيق]
امريكا تترقب ترامب على حبل المحاكمه وليس
الامريكي جو بايدن يرفض التعليق
انخفاض تاريخي للبطاله في السعوديه
مستهدفات الرؤيه تقترب والمرحله القادمه
لتحسين الوظائف
اول تسعه ايام من شهر رمضان تسعه ملايين
راكب عبر شبكه الحافلات من والى المسجد
الحرام
فايروس ماربل يقلق افريقيا والسعوديه تدعو
لتجنب السفر الى غينيا الاستوائيه
وتنزانيا
[تصفيق]
ولعبه البيادر تدخل سباق الاهتمامات مع
الكره الطائره رياضه رمضانيه حديثه في
السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد اكثر من تسعه ملايين
راكب تنقلوا في مكه المكرمه خلال اول
ثمانيه ايام من شهر رمضان عبر الحافلات
هذا ما كشفته النقابه العامه للسيارات
العربيه التي خصصت 16 مسارا لنقل
المعتمرين الى الحرم المكي عبر اسطول مكون
من ثلاثه الاف حافله كشفت النقابه العمال
السيارات بان عدد رحلات النقل
بلغ 27 الف رحله منذ بدايه شهر رمضان وحتى
اليوم
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك اذا عدد كبير
للحافلات في مكه المكرمه
حدثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل هذه الارقام ورحلت
هذه الحاف
بالفعل خالد موسم رمضان هذا العام هو موسم
للعمره مختلف كليا عن اخ عشر سنوات ماضيه
وتحديدا الى ما قبل جائحه فيروس كورونا
نتحدث عن اعداد مليونيه تفيد الى الحرم
المكي بشكل يومي وبحسب المصادر نتحدث على
اكثر من مليون و200 الف مؤتمر ومصلي
يدخلون الى الحرم المكي يوميا وساهمت طبعا
منظومه النقل العام في العاصمه المقدسه
بنقلهم الى الحرم المكي بشكل يومي عبر
اسطول يصل الى 3000 حافله نقف الان من وسط
احدى محطات النقل العام هنا في في منشاه
الجمرات هذه المحطه التي تقوم بنقل
المعتمرين والمصلين من والى الحرم المكي
في مده زمنيه لا تتجاوز ال16 دقيقه عبر
مسار ترددي نتحدث في مكه فقط هنالك تسعه
مواقف وهنالك في خمسه مواقف خارجيه وهي
تسمى المواقف الطرفيه على حدود العاصمه
المقدسه تتحدثنا بحسب الاحصائيات انه منذ
اليوم الاول من وحتى الان اكثر من 230 الف
مركبه تم ايقافها في المواقف الطرفيه
واستقلال اصحابها لهذه الحافلات وصولا الى
الحرم المكي منظومه النقل العام اليوم من
المنظومات النقل المهمه التي تسامح في
تساهم في انجاح موسم العمره بشكل كبير
وتخفيف الزحام والتكدسات البشريه
والمروريه والمركبات في المنطقه المركزيه
في الحرم المكي اليوم رحله المعتمر هي
رحله مختلفه فيما يتعلق بعمليه النقل على
سبيل المثال من قادم من ياتي من خارج
العاصمه المقدسه يستطيع الوصول الى خمسه
مواقف طرفيه على سبيل المثال موقف الزايدي
يستطيع من خلاله ركوب الحافله ووصوله الى
الحرم المكي في مده تتجاوز النصف الساعه
ومن ثم يتوجه بعد ذلك عند العوده ايضا الى
مواقف داخليه تقع بالقرب من الحرم المكي
توصله مجددا الى مركبته فيما يتعلق لاهالي
سكان العاصمه المقدسه هنالك تسعه مواقف
داخليه في العاصمه يستطيع من خلالها سكان
ومقيمي واهالي مكه ركوب هذه الحافلات عبر
تسعه مواقف منتشره في العاصمه المقدسه
يستطيع من خلاله ايقاف مركبتي بهذه
المواقف واستقلال الحافله وصولا الى الحرم
المكي نتحدث على منظومه نقل كبيره جدا
تعمل على مدار الساعه نتحدث على ارقام
كبيره سجلتها النقابه العامه للسيارات وهي
الجهه المشرفه على هذه الحافلات وتشغيلها
في موسم العمره كل هذه الحافلات بها
سائقين تم تدريبهم وتاهيلهم وكذلك هنالك
مشرفين من النقابه العامه يعملون عبر غرفه
عمليات مشتركه على مدار اليوم للتاكد من
خدمه وسلامه والتسهيل على المعتمرين كل
هذه الحافلات هي مكيفه بشكل كامل وتحفظ
سلامه المعتمرين وتشهد اقبال كبير على
مدار الساعه وفي اوقات مختلفه تماما اذا
تحدثنا نريد ان ناخذكم في جوله داخل هذه
الحافله نشاهد هنالك غرف مخصصه يتم قطع
التذاكر من خلالها ومن ثم الاتجاه الى هذه
الحافله هنالك رجال الامن يشاركون في
التنظيم وايضا في جوله سريعه قبل ان ننهي
هذا البث كما نشاهد زميلنا يمكن عصام
يعطينا الصوره لهذه الحافلات التي تعتبر
مجهزه بالكامل ومدربه السائقين على
قيادتها بشكل كبير وهي مكيفه طبعا نعم
خالد
شكرا جزيلا لك من مكه المكرمه مراسل
العربيه سلطان السلمي
تشجير الحرم المكي فكره حديثه عملت عليها
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين بتشجير بعض الحوائط
والاعمده المشروع في مرحله الاولى يهدف
الى التخفيف من درجات الحراره وتحسين
البيئه في ساحات الحرم سلسله من الحرمين
مع زمير سلطان السلمي ايضا
[موسيقى]
اللون الاخضر يغطي ساحاتي واعمده المسجد
الحرام بادره تشجير جديده عملت عليها
رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين لخفض درجات الحراره
وتحسين جوده الهواء
[موسيقى]
تعتمد عمليات التسجير في مرحلتها الاوليه
على الحوائط الخضر من خلال تطبيق نظام
الزراعه المائيه وهو نظام يعتمد على زراعه
النبات دون تربه ويهدف المشروع الى
استغلال مياه الوضوء ومعالجتها وتدويرها
والاستفاده منها في ري المسطحات الخضر من
الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي العربيه
في السعوديه وسط هيئه الصحه العامه وقايه
بتجنب السفر الى غينيا الاستوائيه
وتنزانيا لحين السيطره على تفشي فيروس
مارب بورك ونصحت وقايه المواطنين
المتواجدين هناك باتباع الاجراءات
الوقائيه الصادره من وزاره الصحه وهيئه
الصحه العامه فضلا عن اتباع التعليمات
تعليمات السلطات الصحيه المحليه واشارت
الى ان هذه الاجراءات جاءت اثراء اعلان
السلطات الصحيه في غينيا الاستوائيه
من جده ينضم الينا رئيس قسم الباثولوجيا
المناعيه في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
الدكتور اشرف الداتا دكتور اشرف حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه فيروس جديد دكتور
فيروس ماربور سؤال هنا عن هذا الفيروس ما
هو متى وكيف واين
ظهر وكيف ينتقل وهل هو بخطوره معاشه
العالم يعني في كورونا فيروس كورونا
مساء الخير استاذ خالد رمضان مبارك تقبل
الله وساده المشاهدين حقيقه هذا الفيروس
انتشر منذ حوالي سته ستين عاما اذا سنه
في الغرابه في المانيا مدينه فرانكفورت
حيث كان عندهم بعض القرده يعملون عليها
بحوثات الذي استوردوها من افريقيا ومن ثم
انتقل الفيروس من القرده الى العلماء
الالمان في تحديدا في مدينه ماربو ولهذا
يسمى بفيروس ماربو وهذا الفيروس ينتمي الى
فصيله ما نسميه الفيلو فيروسس فيروسات
الفيلو التي يتبع اليها ايضا بيروت او
ينتمي اليها فيروس الايبولا اي انه من
اخطر الفيروسات المعروفه لدينا حتى حيث ان
هذا الفيروس عندما يصيب الاشخاص
يعني العدوى تنتقل بصعوبه ولكن عندما يصيب
الاشخاص فان المرض يعني يكون شديد جدا
يبدا بالام شديد في منطقه خصوص المنطقه
الامعاء والمعده والام في الراس ايضا ومن
ثم تقيؤ شديد واسهال شديد والام شديده في
الجسم يتبعها تقريبا في اليوم العاشر من
حدوث الاعراض ميوعه حاده في الدم مما يؤدي
الى النزيف داخلي ومن ثم الموت في الكثير
من الحالات دكتور منظمه الصحه العالميه
قيمت مخاطره على مستوى المحلي في تنزانيا
مثلا بانه مرتفع لكن على المستوى العالمي
قالت بانه الخطر منخفض مع انه حتى معدل
الوفيات يعني يصل الى نسبه 90% في المناطق
المقتضه في باب السكان ووضعوا بعض الاعداد
يعني
لهذه الاصابات في بعض الدول هل يمكن
ان يحدث
الاخطر ربما ان يتحول الخطر الى المستوى
العالمي يعني تصبح هناك عدوى تنتقل على
مستوى العالم ويصبح الى مستوى متوسط او
مرتفع
نعم هذا سؤال وجيه مهم جدا هو الانتقال
للفيروس في تنزانيا فعلا كان عدد الوفيات
توصل حوالي 90% وهذا الرقم القياسي حتى
الان الذي لاحظناه لاول مره منذ 60 عاما
ولكن ولهذا اعلنت منظمه الصحه العاميه
ربما تحديدا تنزانيه انها يعني منطقه
كثيره معرضه لانتشار هذا الفيروس بسبب انه
لاول مره يظهر في تنزانيا هذا الفيروس
مستوطن فقط في وسط وغرب افريقيا ولاول مره
ينتشر في تنزانيه او على الاقل يتحدثون او
يسجلون حالات في تنزانيه
وكانت حالات خطره كما ذكرت ومعظمها
توفي من خطر هذه الحالات وهذا السبب الذي
ادى الى يعني اصدار يعني
قوي عن منظمه الصحه العالميه بان هذا
الفيروس او او ربما منطقه تنزيل تحديدا
تكون منطقه قطر عالميا ولكن دعني اسمح لي
استاذ خالد ان اؤكد للجمهور ان هذا
الفيروس ليس مثل فيروس الكورونا على سبيل
المثال وانما فيروس يبقى في هذه المنطقه
ولن يخرج منها نكاد نجزم ذلك لانه لا
ينتقل
مصاب بهذا المرض دكتور وصل الى اي منطقه
من مناطق العالميه الى السعوديه على سبيل
المثال هذه احتمالات النقل العدوى كيف
تكون خاصه انه يقال بانه وسائل انتشاره
اسهل من مكان مع الكورونا يعني ممكن يكون
من الاسطح ربما ملامسه بعض الاسطح التي
لمسها هذا الشخص سبب في اصابه الشخص بهذا
الفيروس
نعم هو نقول الاحتكاك المباشر او ايضا لمس
الاشياء التي يعني تحتوي على افرازات
الاشخاص المصابين مثل الملابس او يعني
غطاء الاسره هذا ربما يؤدي ايضا
العدو واذا شخص على سبيل الافتراضيه لم
تحصل حتى الان ان يخرج هذا الفيروس من
افريقيا منذ 60 عام منذ نشاته في المانيا
لاول مره وبعدها بقي في افريقيا ولكن انت
تقول لاول مره فبالتالي احتمالاتا يصل الى
مناطق اقراها واحتمال وارد جدا اليوم صحيح
نعم نعم حتى الان لا نعرف لماذا انتشر في
تنزيله هل
الخفافيش
غيرت يعني تصرفاته هل البشر غيروا
تصرفاتهم ام انهم كان موجود في تنزانيه
واول مره يقرون به هذه الاشياء تناقش
حاليا طب خلينا في السيناريو
جاء احد من تنزانيا مصاب بهذا المرض
احتمالات نقله لعدوى الاصابه في اي منطقه
يصل الى كم تصل
وباي شكل ممكن تنتشر هذه العدوى
نعم احتمال وارد استاذ خالد ولكن ضئيل جدا
ضئيل جدا ويجب الاحتكاك المباشر ولمس
الافرازات المعديه التي افرزها هذا الشخص
المصاب وعاده تكون الاعراض موجوده عنده
اين فتره الحضانه تقريبا من اثنين الى 20
يوما وبعدما تظهر الاعراض وان ظهرت
الاعراض يكون في ذروه العدوى فانه يكون
عنده اعراض معروف انه عنده المرض وبالرغم
من ذلك فقط في هذه الحالات يعني اصابه شخص
او لمسه شخص بطريقه مباشره ربما تنتقل
اليه العدو واذا انتقلت هذه العدوى لشخص
اخر من السهل السيطره على هذا الفيروس ليس
مثل الكورون من عن طريق العزل عن طريق عزل
الاشخاص بطريقه محكمه ومن ثم لا يستطيعون
نقل الفيروس عن طريق مثلا الهواء انا
اشكرك شكر جزيلا لهذه المعلومات الدكتور
اشرف الداده رئيس قسم الباثولوجيا
المناعيه في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي من
جده شكرا لك دكتور
بعد الافطار وقبل السحور وقت ذهبي يمارس
فيه الكثير رياضات بعضها تنتشر في رمضان
فقط واخرى دخلت على الخط البادل وكره
الطائره بين
بساطه الطائره والبادل ينقسم محبو الرياضه
في رمضان نتابع هذه القصه
سرعان ما اصبح مضرب البادي الجزء الرئيسيا
من هوايه شباب تخلوا عن الكره الطائره في
رمضان
وجدبته ملاعب البادل الساحره التي انتشرت
بشكل لافت في الرياض
رياضه البادل جديده علينا يعني جاءت في
الاونه الاخيره
قوانينها سهله مقاربه للتنس بشكل اسهل
فيها متعه متعه اهتمت ممكن جربت معنا قبل
شوي اللي يفهم قوانينها بكل سهوله استمتع
فيها حقيقه كل لعبه لها اجواء وطقوسها لكن
انا بالنسبه لي اشوف لعبه البدل افضل
بكثير بالرغم من وجود ملاعب للطائره في
حدائق الاحيان مهيئه اكثر الا ان محب كره
الطائره وتحديدا في رمضان لا زالوا يحبون
اجوائها البسيطه القديمه وتحديدا المتمثله
في ملاعب ترابيه وسط الاحياء
[تصفيق]
الوضع هنا مختلف الاجواء الحماسيه
والتشجيع والبساطه هي التي تطفي طابعا
خاصا للكره الطائره تجمع مباراه الكره
الطائره ابناء الحي في مساحه واحده
العمر ليس مهما للتفاعل مع اي نقطه يحصدها
احد الفريقين كل شيء بسيط هنا ولا يخضع
لقوانين صارمه كما لعبه البادل
اكثر شيء بسيط في الملعب هو لبس الحكم
لبسك كانك رايح دوام ولا رايح مناسبه
بينما اشوفك تتحكم في
صراحه واتفاجات كذا وجيت الملعب وانا
الحاكم الدولي هنا كل يوم حكم لكن عاد
اليوم جينا رسمي لعبه الطائره مثل ما
تشوفون لعبه ممتعه تجمع الكبار والصغار
لعبه رمضانيه زين واكثر ما يتشلون فيها
بالوقت هذا زين واكثر الملاعب شوف هناك
وهناك كل الملاعب يعني مليانه ما شاء الله
تبارك الله هي من اخف الالعاب وافضل
الالعاب
بالرغم من حداثه ملاعب البادل وشكلها
الجذاب الا ان اجواء الكره الطائره لا
تزال تشكل روتينا رمضانيا لدى محبيها
فهل تاخذ البادل حصه اكبر من الكره
الطائره مستقبلا عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه الرياض
[تصفيق]
امريكا تترقب ترامب على حبل المحاكمه
ورئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يرفض التعليق
انخفاض تاريخي للبطاله في السعوديه
مستهدفات الرؤيه تقترب والمرحله القادمه
لتحسين الوظائف
اول تسعه ايام من شهر رمضان تسعه ملايين
راكب عبر شبكه الحافلات من والى المسجد
الحرم
فيروس مارفل يقلقه افريقيا والسعوديه تدعو
لتجنب السفر الى غينيا الاستوائيه وتنساني
لعبه البادل تدخل سباق الاهتمامات مع
الكره الطائره رياضه رمضانيه حديثه في
السعوديه
شكرا للمتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]